very unique candy flavored mac and
cheese
i don't know i'm just i'm a savory
person so i don't know about the cotton
candy
mac and cheese what do you guys think
that's a kid's version of utopia because
every kid
loves mac and cheese and every kid loves
candy what we've done is we've married
the chocolate and peanut butter of mac
and cheese and candy so there's not a
kid in the world who say no
but i as an adult would say no yeah i
got to tell you this
nothing says i love you than candy mac
and cheese so i put i would put candles
out
a nice rose ted are you telling me and
they go
italy mac and cheese it would even use
syrup jewelry and chocolate
hey why not never
never yeah listen denise has spoken
never ted dee let's talk later okay
i need some tips from you so you know
all right
50 degrees the high for the day 37
overnight for the low it was a
chilly day today because this is where
we should be my friends 59 degrees
haven't seen that lately so it was a
chilly to cold day today and
temperatures will warm up a little for
tomorrow but still be below normal 44
right now centennial hills
summerlin same for you 46 for aliante
downtown 48
50 even for sunrise manor green valley
you're at 50 even 48 for rhodes ranch
mountains edge in henderson
checking in right now at 48 degrees all
right outside of town 45
for prompt just a digit below that for
those of you joining us from sandy
valley we've got a lot of eight news now
viewers out there in sandy valley
searchlight 40 even waffle 52 and now
look at kingman we added you on there 41
degrees currently
for a temperature radar network now
sweeping around we had a few
sprinkles this morning that was it
nothing to amount to much at all but you
look to the west and this is what we're
watching and tracking that rain and
we're talking
heavy rain as well changing over to feet
of snow in the mountains
again this is that system that's tapping
what we call the atmospheric river
you can see there's no breaks in this
rainfall and it will be moving its way
north to south into southern california
mudslides strong winds and of course you
have those burn scarred areas from the
wildfires of summer that's going to
we're going to see
mudslides from that just because we have
so much rain
over the terrain that's already been
just decimated by the wildfires so
here's how it looks for tomorrow not an
issue tomorrow morning
we get to friday overnight
all right friday i should say friday
morning there we go into
friday midday you'll see those numbers
start to decrease a little more so it
looks like a more
maybe a morning event also friday midday
and then the afternoon it starts to
taper off a little bit
one thing's for sure we are expecting
slick roads so please be
careful rain for sure for sure going to
be high wind going to be up to the
moderate readings slow level snow
not going to happen okay the snow levels
will be at 5 000 feet
so the mountains will get snow well
we'll just get rain here
46 degrees at 7 p.m light winds 44 at 9
pm
winds stay light again mostly cloudy
skies for eight news now at 11 43
degrees
winds less than 10 an hour be also
tomorrow morning too before those winds
start to pick up later on in the day
especially for the we are for friday i
should say showers and breezy look at
that your weekend drier
and the next week and that eight day
forecast chance of showers returns on
wednesday
brian back over to you